If you just laughed out loud after watching that cat...
...or countless other cat videos online, keep it up.
They're good for your health.
Hey everyone, I'm Sean Dowling from Buzz60...
...and new research is basically telling me that how I spend my Friday nights...
...is keeping the doctor away.
Indiana University media school researchers surveyed nearly 7,000 people...
...for a study in computers and human behavior,...
...about viewing cat videos and how it affects their moods.
What did they find?
Participants reported cute cat videos like this had a positive effect on them,...
...making them feel more energetic.
They also had fewer negative emotions like sadness or anger.
So turn that frown upside down, Grumpy Cat.
The study also showed people watch cat videos when they're at work...
...or supposed to be studying, but they didn't feel guilty procrastinating...
...because they got a good laugh out of it.
And how could you not?
Researchers also point out that last year,...
...cat videos were watched 26 billion times on Youtube,...
...more than any other category on the site.
But if everyone is watching cat videos while they're supposed to be working,...
...how is anything actually getting done?
Buzz60.
Now you know, pass it on.